I feel like you're pulling a prank on me
hi I'm Owen I'm a food content creator
based out of Los Angeles hi I'm Gideon
I'm based in Dayton Ohio I'm also a food
content creator so we're doing something
really cool today we're swapping our
favorite childhood snacks so I was born
in Italy spent my time half in Florida
half in Italy Summers were spent in my
Anonymous kitchen so a lot of these
snacks will be pretty much Italian
excited I was born and raised in the
Philippines for like my first 13 years
of my life and excited for you to try it
you ready definitely I'm hungry
okay I feel like I've had those before
really are they filled with chocolate
yeah but it's like I guess this is the
Filipino one sticko sticko I like that
name oh what there's like no chocolate
in here you said these were filled this
is empty hey man don't blame me blame
the sticko guy cheers
it's good honestly I just want chocolate
in here like I thought it would be
filled it's just like empty it's like
they forgot speaking of chocolate we got
pandestele one of my favorite cookies
growing up they're just chocolate and
then they have stars okay so normally I
eat this with milk otherwise just like a
really dry cookie
really dry
I would love some so we now have milk
cheers
dude you had to let it like soak yeah
I'm not a fan of like soggy cookies
though no like not too soggy but like a
good you gotta find the right balance
all right just go for it I feel like if
this had like the cream filling I would
but I'm keeping my my sticko I'm keeping
it all day all right on to the next
snack
[Music]
I recognize this really confused by that
Mick Mick or is it supposed to be milk
milk it's just powder milk powder you
just suck it if you don't need water you
don't make a drink out of it well this
is chocolate milk powder because
chocolate makes everything better have
you hadn't as quick before oh yeah okay
but have you had like the powdered
version where you make it yourself I
don't think so but yeah I like that you
can put more yeah that's why I just do
like one spoonful at a time and then
I'll mix I just got some on here
sorry there you go thank you
it's gonna be strong it's good though
right more I'm kidding oh yeah okay I
brought mcmick everything we need is in
this plate right here I don't believe
you I feel like you're pulling a prank
on me ask Mick mcmah's if I have a dry
cookie the last thing I want is more
powder in my mouth I can't even open
this that's why I brought scissors I got
you bro
that smells like milk it looks really
cool but like I literally just you're
coughing I don't want to Dr like do it
cough with me man
it disintegrates as soon as it touches
like saliva yeah you don't need water I
just need your saliva
last time I had this was probably like
15 years ago I got like powder all over
me now I mean it was a cool I like it
was it's fun right it's fun I love the
name too Mick Mick I'm keeping mine
sorry I'm like there's just no way I
would like go out and get this like ever
time for some more snacks I'm hoping
it's Savory and something I can actually
eat
as a kid I ate a lot of like sweets this
is one of my all-time favorites White
Rabbit so you know what yeah that was
like what my favorite candy okay it
comes wrapped in a paper and you get to
eat it it like melts and I haven't had
it in like over 10 years really it's not
this wrapper you can eat it's this
wrapper it's like a little present
oh it's a lot harder than I remember I
don't remember being like this it just
hurts I'm not gonna lie and it stuck to
my tooth right now it's like a Jolly
Rancher yeah but it does taste the same
it does it's like white Taffy and so
what did you bring me all right bro you
you asked something Savory I got you
prawn crackers or just shrimp flavored
chips by Oishi whoa
I like it a lot I do too man oh it's
like puffy but has Chip qualities a lot
of Agents love like shrimp crackers like
shrimp chips like this I think like this
has like the perfect saltiness because
some brands are just really Bland the
smell is a lot fishier than it actually
tastes I think it's very subtle not
overpowering it tastes better than it
smells though yeah I'm swapping this was
like rock hard not as good as I remember
as much as I love White Rabbit I think
I'm going with the Savory I'm keeping
mine okay you ready for the next one
let's do it let's do it just takes me
back me too actually all right is that a
steak like I used to eat like the cheese
flavor but I remember when this was
dropped it like changed the game I hope
it tastes like
steak
um it smells like just a standard chip
really yeah okay not to be too critical
but like what is this like this is a
crumb you know what I'm saying like it's
too small no okay it's not that deep Bro
zero resemblance of steak but it's great
it's good right there's no big chips in
here it's all
right there dude that you think this is
big as big as it gets man I think I
don't know about that I feel like this
would pair very nicely with what we have
right here I know it looks like a very
boring ham and cheese sandwich and
that's because it is but a little back
story my grandma my nana used to make
this for me in the afternoons so in
Italy it's actually called tossed you're
basically saying toast in a European
accent but that's what it's called
cheers
I mean you can't go wrong with ham and
cheese man
well I'm just having my moment yeah you
know sometimes it's just the simple
things you know but yeah this is really
good I've been keeping mine all day I'm
swapping mine all right well let's try
some more
whoa bring in the milk I'm gonna need
milk for this as well
this just reminds me of winter and
Christmas this is buccane they're
cookies with it's like a shortbread
taste either I go to Italy on Christmas
or my nana used to visit us in Florida
and she would bring this to us okay
normally they should be fully intact
these are a little crushed
yeah there's way better than the
chocolate one to be honest with you and
I'm a chocolate guy and I prefer this
yeah like you said shortly shortbread
yeah yeah and I'm a big fan of
shortbread so what did you bring me it
looks like corn yes in a bag yes this is
sweet corn actually one of like my
favorite snacks it's pretty balanced
like it's sweet but it's also Savory you
know that
I mean that bag is just asking to be
copped you want to pop it
oh this is just not asking to be popped
dude what is this made out of
I feel I got you
wow that like took a lot of energy on me
exit here you go man oh you're like
little tough balls yeah
hmm you taste the corn for sure I wish
it was a little saltier really yeah
that's something I can eat like
the whole bag that just once in it I
would almost prefer if this came on like
a cob it was like an actual core yeah I
think that'd be really fun to like
recreate yeah you know what I mean like
it's no all right maybe that's just me
but you know I would probably swap just
because like Savory and like if I'm
snacking I'm probably gonna pick that
but like Nostalgia Christmas Nana like I
gotta keep it you know right as much as
I love your story man so you know so
sweet but um keeping my uh my sweet corn
chips all right okay I think it's time
for our last snack bring it on
more corn bro corn yeah we love corn in
the Philippines man so this is a boy
bawang I still remember the first time
I've had it my uncle just randomly like
showed up and he just tossed me a bag
he's like here you're welcome and I'm
like okay like one at a time or multiple
multiple
this is adobo flavor not getting much of
that it tastes like a seasoned corn
Fritter nut of sorts well it says it's
just fried corn oh my God then that my
description was on point then but I get
this over chips probably not really you
know how airlines are like here are your
nuts like peanuts I think this should be
a replacement it's better right yeah
they're better than like regular peanuts
and stuff this is the thing I used to
like when I would eat this I'm gonna put
like vinegar just to balance it out this
is cool though I've never seen that you
put it in the bag yeah just put in the
bag
shake it but I just thought it was good
I don't know if other people do it in
the Philippines
it doesn't taste like straight vinegar
at all just gives it that like little
kick I don't know I think it just brings
out the other seasonings more the acid
just really elevates it you know have
you had one of these before weren't
those banned so they used to not be
available in the states when I would go
to Italy we used to eat this all the
time I still eat them all the time and
they all come with a toy which is the
best part that's what I was hoping I was
like is there a toy this is
the yummy side they provide a little
spoon for you you have to build it too
they're usually really cool toys too
mine's built already though okay some
come already built that's actually
really cool have you had this before no
no no no oh dude you're you're in for a
treat so the best way to do this you
like get half of the chocolate stuff and
then one ball and then you eat it all in
one like go it's just like it's unreal
it's all over my lips yeah it's very
messy I kind of want some milk
isn't that like just so good come on
it's really good yeah like the texture
of a KitKat the little ball thing just
like you're eating the toast if you
haven't had one you'd need to go and try
one like these things are insane
oh yes there's a lot of pieces to that
it looks about it looks like he's
dancing he's doing he's like twerking I
feel like I can eat more of this when
I'm like you know this is really fun
build a toy and you're gonna pick
vinegar in a bag yeah I don't want to
hurt my uncle's feelings
I'm keeping mine too all right that was
a lot of fun man it was I uh loved
hearing about your stories in the
Philippines no milk in bag though next
time I think I drank enough milk today
all right and for next week all right
thank you guys so much for watching if
you have a favorite snack leave it in
the comments below we'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]